just what tricks do the batman director
matt reeves and his crew have up their
sleeves for audiences could the riddle
be on us keep watching for one big twist
the movie has in store batman has his
hands full in the newest entry to the
dark knight movie mythos this time
around the riddler is a serial killer
targeting gotham's elite to bring their
corruption to light catwoman seems like
she may be an ally but as tends to be
the case throughout her history with the
bat she causes her own share of
headaches and the penguin rubs elbows
with the most dangerous criminals in all
of gotham through his nightclub batman's
arguably the busiest person in gotham
and that's just the beginning of his
problems however people with fun
nicknames who sometimes wear costumes
are only part of the equation there are
plenty of criminals who keep a lower
profile and that's where carmine falcone
enters the picture he's a crime lord
who's awfully chummy with penguin and
has a history of keeping the most
powerful people in the city under his
thumb he's a menacing force that lurks
in the shadows and while he may not be
as flashy he's just as if not more
terrifying given his proclivity for
criminal activity it makes one of the
movie's primary twists all the more
shocking in the batman riddler sets out
to reveal a massive conspiracy in which
gotham's elite power brokers took funds
from the wayne foundation's renewal
project the project had dedicated one
billion dollars per year to help
gothamites but the conspiracists line
their own pockets instead but there's a
rat in their midst then the riddler
wants this individual to come to light
to pay for their actions batman and
police lieutenant james gordon attempt
to find this rat knowing he'll be the
next riddler victim they have several
guesses initially with the only clue
being the spanish phrase rata alada
which roughly translates to winged rat
at first batman assumes the rap must be
the penguin since penguins have wings
when that turns out to be a dead end he
wonders if he's at the center of this
conspiracy somehow since bats are
sometimes derogatorily called rats with
wings but that's when he has a
realization that falcone has falcon
right there in the name and falcons have
wings
it all adds up to a sinister
riddle riddler
riddler
it's a development that likely took
plenty of fans by surprise in the comics
falcone is a ruthless mob boss known as
the roman in honor of his ruthless
demeanor he keeps more to the shadows in
the batman and his turn as the rat is a
significant departure from his
depictions in the comics tv shows and
other movies no doubt it took plenty of
audience members by surprise just one of
the many shocking moments to be found in
the batman carmine falcone doesn't get a
ton of screen time into batman but he
makes excellent use of the scenes he
does appear in it goes along perfectly
with his attitude he can be a more
effective crime lord if he keeps a low
profile and stays out of the public eye
as often as possible however it's clear
he gets into ample trouble behind the
scenes as it turns out he's not just a
rat but also the father of a cat he's
selena kyle aka catwoman's dad granted
some fans were probably more likely to
see this particular twist coming seeing
how there's precedent for it in the
comic books their relationship is hinted
at in the long halloween in its sequel
in the movie catwoman knows for sure
that falcone is her father but he's
completely unaware of her existence he
only learns the truth when she reveals
herself to him and mentions her mother
maria kyle to his face selena kyle may
be okay with letting palconee live in
the comics but she's out for blood in
the batman missing her chance for
revenge when batman enters the picture
and stops her before she does something
she might regret this isn't the first
time carmine falcone has appeared in a
live action film he was a key part of
batman begins but reeves and crew have
created a terrifying mobster who's
unlike any iteration in the past
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]